das ist ein desaster gerade noch hatte
das mission steam den bohrer der mars
sonde inside wieder ans laufen bekommen
nachdem er stecken geblieben war und
jetzt ist es noch schlimmer
der bohrer ist aus dem loch gehüpft was
nun ist die mission gescheitert krieg
zum science fiction gibt es spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich ein disaster monate
lang arbeiteten die fachleute an einer
idee dem bohrer wieder ans laufen zu
bekommen und dann vor wenigen tagen ging
der plan der nasa und des deutschen
zentrums für luft- und raumfahrt dlr auf
der maas maulwurf kam wieder mit dem
bohren voran nachdem der maßnahme also
mehr als ein halbes jahr lang in einer
tiefe von nur 30 zentimetern
festgesteckt hatte hatte er sich
innerhalb von einer woche immerhin um
zwei zentimeter bewegt es war ein
kleiner fortschritt und ein erfolg
hilfestellung kam vom roboterarm der
sonde der den bohrer seitlich an das
gestein drückte und so für die
notwendige reibung sorgte ansagen des
jahres 2009 10 war der bohrer an den
start gegangen doch schon nach rund vier
stunden endete seine arbeit in einer
tragödie 4000 hammerschläge lang klappte
alles super doch plötzlich ging gar
nichts mehr und der maulwurf kippte
seitlich um 15 grad die fachleute
tüftelt monatelang daran den nasa
maulwurf wieder zum graben zu bringen
das große problem die fehlende reibung
an der seite das steht seit juni 2009 10
als ursache für das problem fest es war
also keinen felsbrocken also gott sei
dank einer dem weg war sondern die wohl
seltsamen eigenschaften der mars erde
und jetzt hat sie wohl die mars erde
dazu geführt dass der gesamte bohrer
wieder zur hälfte aus dem bohrloch
gehüpft ist dazu die nasa vorläufige
untersuchungen deuten auf ungewöhnliche
bodenverhältnisse auf dem roten planeten
hin dass internationale mission steam
entwickelt die nächsten schritte um ihn
wieder herab zu senken
der nächste schritt besteht darin
festzustellen wie sicher es ist ins
roboterarm vom maulwurf recht zu bewegen
um die situation besser einschätzen zu
können
das team prüft weiterhin die daten und
wird in den weg
zum tagen einen plan ausarbeiten jetzt
könnte möglicherweise geröll helfen denn
damit könnte auch druck ausgeübt werden
der für das graben notwendig ist
eigentlich soll die raumsonde jahr sich
bis zu fünf metern tiefe in den mars
boden graben um dann den wärmefluss aus
dem inneren des roten planeten
detailliert zu erkunden
ermöglicht wird das durch die
kombination aus bohrhammer und eines
temperatur sensors dadurch kann die
wärmeverteilung im maß gemessen werden
und vor allem auch die beschaffenheit
des mars inneren analysiert werden wir
würden also eine menge über den mars
erfahren wenn alles klappen würde
das steht jetzt allerdings in den
sternen rohwer der neugierige mit noch
mehr infos auch über insight vom neuen
kanal im wissenschafts netzwerk also
jetzt auf klicken
1054 über raum tv mega fundierte
berichte also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren auf jeden fall bis dann
bleibt dran